die ebola epidemie in der demokratischen
republik kongo nimmt einfach kein ende
nicht nur dass sie jetzt die zweitgrößte
epidemie aller zeiten ist die
opferzahlen steigen und steigen und das
immer schneller
droht uns jetzt wieder eine pandemie wie
schon vor einigen jahren in westafrika
als die ersten infizierten außerhalb von
afrika auftauchten klicks um
science-fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierendes 1
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
schon im letzten jahr war der ausbruch
für beendet erklärt worden doch jetzt
stattdessen steigt die zahl der
infizierten immer schneller und das ein
jahr nach dem ausbruch die ebola
epidemie scheint einfach nicht zu
stoppen zu sein
dabei hatten die behörden anfänglich
gemeinsam mit der
weltgesundheitsorganisation wer wirklich
sehr gute arbeit geleistet die epidemie
wurde schnell eingedämmt und im
gegensatz zum ausbruch 2014 wurde im
kongo ein experimenteller impfstoff
eingesetzt
ebola ist ein fieber das in rund der
hälfte der fälle oder sogar mehr zum tod
führt es beginnt relativ harmlos wie
eine grippe aber im weiteren verlauf
fangen die opfer an
überall zu bluten und sterben
schließlich an multiplem organversagen
übertragen wird die krankheit meistens
von sogenannten reservoir würden und das
sind wildtiere die gejagt und gegessen
werden durch die abholzung von wäldern
rücken die menschen immer näher an diese
populationen heran und jagen dann
flughunde affen oder zum beispiel
stachelschweine dieses buschfleisch
führt dann meistens zum ausbruch der
seuche jetzt gibt es in afrika immer
mehr todesfälle und neuerkrankungen in
der letzten aprilwoche waren es 83 tote
und 126 neuerkrankungen verdachtsfälle
sind hier noch nicht eingerechnet eine
dramatische entwicklung ende märz wurden
noch tausende infizierte gezählt jetzt
sind es schon mehr als 1500 und zwar
insgesamt im letzten jahr
und genau so ist auch die anzahl der
todesfälle gestiegen von zuletzt
insgesamt 630 auf 950 vor allem in den
provinzen nord kivu und uri stoßen die
helfer und helferinnen auf widerstand
hier sind zahlreiche milizen unterwegs
und greifen die ebola stationen an
ende april wurde ein arzt getötet zudem
gibt es auch dort ein wie immer in den
ebola gebieten ein akzeptanzproblem
aberglaube
jürgens theorien und stammes riten
verhindern den richtigen umgang mit den
infizierten verbreitet sich die
krankheit immer weiter nachdem es vor
einem jahr noch mit wenigen erkrankten
und wenigen todesfällen begonnen hatte
nimmt die epidemie jetzt deutlich an
fahrt auf dass das trotz impfung und der
dieses mal schnellen reaktion der
weltgesundheitsorganisation passiert ist
sehr bedenklich
wir halten euch auf dem laufenden hier
geht es weiter mit dafür drauf kriegen
einer playlist mit allen infos zum
aktuellen ebola ausbruch in der
demokratischen republik kongo
wenn ihr noch einmal den verlauf sehen
wollt dann schaut euch diese playlist an
bis dann bleibt dran